[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans votre rendez-vous
envies de lecture
aujourd'hui nous avons trois invités
autour de la table véronique paulhan
merotto bonjour vous avez directrice du
réseau des médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et vous êtes
venu nous parler d'une revue oui j'avais
envie aujourd'hui de vous parler d'une
revue trimestrielle qui s'appelle oui
demain très bien leur hangar un bonjour
vous êtes libraire aux pavés du canal
des gérants du pavé du canal c'est ça
tout vous avez eu un coup de coeur pour
arias beck qui a fait la marcheuse voilà
quelque chose au darfour entre récit
politique de guerre et précis homérique
entre les deux tout a coûté et notre
code chroniqueurs habituels
jacques fournier bonjour je prends d'un
abonnement bonjour donc moi je vous
dirige les itinéraires politique de
saint quentin en yvelines qui services
de la direction du rayonnement culturel
et donc je vous présente et je vous
parlais de du livre de joseph andras de
nos frères blessés qui évoque une page
de la guerre d'algérie parfait on vous
écoute
cette page c'est là c'est l'assassinât
par l'état français de fernand yveton
qui était un ouvrier français qui a été
le seul européen guillotiné pendant la
guerre d'algérie
parce qu'il l'a il avait pris fait et
cause pour la pour l'algérie libre et il
a eu le malheur de tomber entre les
pattes delà de la justice la police et
l'armée de la justice et la police
française pour avoir posé une bombe dans
un local technique une bombe qui n'a pas
explosé qui n'aurait fait absolument
aucune victime mais il est tombé au
mauvais moment
politiquement il a été torturé et
assassiné après un procès complètement
inéquitable et donc ce livre de joseph
andras coma j'ai découvert on nous l'a
offert on a offert il ya peu de temps et
je ne connaissais pas du tout j'ai
découvert depuis qu'il a écrit kanaky
donc qui vient de sortir aussi chef au
sud sur la rentrée littéraire 2018 donc
ce livre de 2016 publié chez babel en
poche parle de cette page méconnue de
l'histoire de la manière dont dont un
européen qui avait un engagement
politique était un simple ouvrier qui
est allé vivre en algérie parce qu'il y
avait du travail là bas se retrouve pris
dans un engrenage dont il ne peut
absolument pas sortir parce que ça sa
cause et il est il est considéré comme
un terroriste comme un assassin en
plaine en pleine guerre d'algérie qui ne
dit pas encore son nom et est donc cette
c'est une manière c'est un c'est une
manière de plaidoyer qu'a voulu écrire
andrade je pense avec une écriture
incisive rapide et des chapitres très
courts qui raconte à la fois le moment
de la torture ce sont des pages très dur
comment il est rentré dans cette dans
cet engagement politique qu'ils
n'avaient pas avant
comment il a rencontré celle qui est
devenue sa femme hélène et toute cette
histoire jusqu'à son exécution et je
trouve qu'en plus ce livre avait
complètement actualité avec la sphère
maurice audin qui a été mise au jour là
récemment par les excuses porté par
emmanuel macron auprès de la veuve de
maurice audin la demande et surtout à
l'insistance de cédric villani
mathématicien comme maurice audin et
donc cette reconnaissance du
comportement inadmissible d'un état sur
des individus qui n'ont fait que prendre
une position politique
voilà et donc c'est ce livre là moi même
a complètement bouleversé parce qu'en
plus c'est une c'est une véritable
écriture que j'ai découverte que je
trouve quand même assez rare dans le
roman donc la littérature à un rôle de
réparation par rapport à l'histoire elle
un rôle de pas de réparation non de deux
révélations c'est ça c'est une réelle
voie là pour moi c'est le sait le rôle
de la littérature et c'est ça depuis
l'antiquité
c'est à dire que depuis que les l'homme
c'est écrire il dit il dit que le monde
va mal et on essaye de faire en sorte
qu'ils aillent mieux aussi
et ça coïncide avec votre actualité oui
en plus oui et on va dire ça peut
concert coïncide avec l'actualité des
itinéraires politique puisque du 10 au
17 novembre nous organisons la semaine
des écrivains persécutés emprisonnés
empêcher donc et une rencontre avec
trois écrivains réfugié en france qui
ont connu dans leur pays des moments
difficiles pour fait d'écriture on aura
une journaliste du zimbabwe un rappeur
du soudan et est un écrivain du de
guinée conakry et il y aura une
rencontre le 15 novembre à la batterie à
guyancourt avec une performance du
tympan
du tympan marteau mais aussi le 10
novembre en l'église de saint georges de
trappes
on organise un concert de katy grainger
lee la chanteuse katy grainger lee qui
chantent des chants traditionnels
français irlandais et anglais et dans
laquelle elle va glisser des poèmes de
poètes du xxème siècle qui ont connu ces
moments difficiles à cause de leurs
écrits pour défendre la paix dans le
monde parfait très bien lui en prit il
faut défendre cette littérature c'est au
tard véronique que je vaux mais vous
parlez d'un book à moux et c'est un mix
entre un magazine et un bouquet notre
magazine books
tout à fait moi j'avais envie envie de
vous parler de oui demain parce que je
trouve que c'est une déjà une revue
positive qui qui présente le prisme de
cette revue s'est j'ai pas seulement les
députés c'est vraiment une revue
prospective et sur les thématiques
fortes de
notre société alors évidemment on
retrouve le développement durable
l'économie collaborative le
effectivement tout
toutes les nouvelles technologies mais
c'est toujours
vraiment avec un regard qui se veut
positif et où on est vraiment dans une
dans une volonté de
d'avancement pour l'humanité et qui ai
je vraiment bien aussi c'est que c'est
une revue avec des deux magnifiques jeux
passion voix ou si on peut voir c'est
pas celle là elle mais il ya vraiment
une mise en page
très belle des thématiques qui se
qui vont être là ce que vous montrez
vous montrer oui c'est plus simple que
la maquette et le regard assez une revue
qui se vend bien librairie beaucoup de
oui mais c'est la même lendemain mais
oui mais 21 août six mois sont d'autres
formations des reportages beaucoup plus
haut là c'est plus sociétale assez court
avec une superbe mise en page c'est
certain les fondateurs de la revue sont
les fondateurs de materne françois et
dominique je n'arrive jamais à pigalle
c'est bien cigale fondateur tout en
plastique voilà et créer en 2012 et
c'est un bimestriel très belle revue
qui s'appuie sur le cherche midi éditeur
et un réseau de distribution interforum
exposant toutes les railleries we are
sait on pourrait penser que c'est très
difficile de sortir des grosses revue
assez quel est le prix derrière de 7,12
euros nous aurons assez épaisse mais
c'est courageux de sortir du papier oui
mais je pense à saisir sans publicité et
ce qui est aussi à paris assez osé
menacer ce qui est aussi intéressant de
l'emprunt du d'ailleurs à leur forme en
oui c'est important
21 c'est pareil format très particulier
qu'on ne voyait pas avant et est ce
qu'il faut ce que je pense que c'est
presque un concept c'est à dire qu'on le
retrouve aussi en numérique avec une une
place tout aussi importante en numérique
en format papier et
il mène
des rencontres des forums enfin ils sont
vraiment dans dans un format alors je
vais vous avez aussi une actualité je
crois à la loi mais l'actualité c'est du
moment c'est le lancement de notre
nouveau bibliobus ce réseau des
médiathèques qui va pour le moment en
tournée dans les cinq communes montigny
magny les hameaux trappe elancourt hui
en cours avec des tournées public
et puis détournés plus spécifiques sur
des foyers sur des sur l'air des gens du
voyage vraiment là on fait du culturel
et du social et socioculturel c'est un
mot qui est un peu galvaudé qui utilisé
pour autre chose
et puis une petite dernière chose en
toute fin de mois de novembre nous
allons avoir une semaine consacrée au
jeu organisé par le réseau des
médiathèques qui commencera à villepreux
avec le festi jeu qui va durer tout un
week end qui va être un bel événement
pour adultes et pour enfants enfin
vraiment et puis tout laisse toute la
semaine et à des animations dans les
médiathèques et puis on terminera juste
par là par la nuit du jeu au canal et
par atria la commanderie avec des
des murder party laurent regardeur vous
nous parler de la marcheuse cessa de
samar yazbek est une syrienne
on l'a connue par les portes du néant
qui était son son précédent roman ou là
c'était vraiment un récit de guerre sur
la syrie de nos jours et cette fois ci
sur la marcheuse donc comme je
l'expliquais tout à l'heure il n'y a pas
que le récit de guerre il ya un super
beau si c'est un récit onirique donc
cette vue parle c'est la syrie
aujourd'hui avec ces bombardements
vu par les yeux d'une petite fille
autiste en fait qui a besoin de la main
de sa maman sinon elle se met à marcher
la marche et elle ne s'arrête plus et
donc elle va vivre
la vie d'une syrienne actuellement c'est
à dire les bombardements les gaz tout
cet effondrement de la société et de sa
vie et tout ça par son oeil à l qui lui
permet en fait de se détacher de son
corps par le biais du petit prince ou
d'alice au pays des merveilles
donc il ya des vraiment des passages de
poésie superbe on se transporte avec
elle on arrive à sortir de ce récit
horrible qui est la cause de la guerre à
la quotidienneté c'est ça sur des
passages vraiment superbe de poésie où
elle se détache de tout ça et elle
arrive finalement à trouver quelque
chose pour continuer d'avancer
et voilà donc c'est cette villa de cette
petite enfant qui est prise par les
bombes dans le quartier de la goutte
d'or qui n'a plus rien à manger plus
rien à voir qui est qui qui qui est
pratiquement sur le bord lors de mourir
et qui va quand même réussir à trouver
par le biais de la littérature quelques
portes de sortie pour s'échapper
totalement de ce qu'elle peut voir où ce
qu'elle a vécu ce que elle va voir quand
même sa maman nourrir son frère se faire
assassiner enfin voilà des choses très
lourde et et on sort de ce bouquin en
colère quoi c'est pourquoi on réagit pas
plus vis-à-vis de la situation actuelle
en syrie
qu'est ce qu'on fait ou qu'est ce qu'on
ne fait pas et voilà et c'est vraiment
un grand coup vraiment moi ça a été mon
bouquin de la rentrée celui-là ça a été
je me suis pris vraiment ce livre en
réflexion parce que voilà on est
totalement validé oui c'est ça
complètement et puis figure de
l'opposition à bachar el-assad
complètement
oui si les réfugiés en france et à les
redémarrer que sa fille lui car c'est ça
et son premier départ du nez on était
vraiment à charge contre le régime
et cette fois ci il ya ce côté
littéraire qui est vraiment sublime vous
avez quelques un petit mot très rapide
sur votre actualité très rapide oui on a
quand même si date nous qui arrivent là
donc après cyril dion et amélie nothomb
on va avoir un auteur jeunesse qui est
journée duo le 10 novembre on va avoir
des auteurs locaux le 17 novembre
donc on soit six auteurs locaux lan du
cru ensuite on a un petit atelier de
cosmétiques bio avec des pharmaciennes
ensuite on a de la bd 1er décembre avec
chad chaibi l'ouest lahti et on finit
avec de la littérature avec estelle
sarah bull qui dont on a parlé sur la
rentrée littéraire donc qui viendra
clôturer notre part notre année 2010
merci de nous avoir suivis pour ce
numéro merci à vous tous d'être venus
remplir cette émission avec vos coups de
coeur et on se retrouve très bientôt sur
tv 78 a très bien peu merci au revoir
[Musique]